okay Alexa bliss last time you're with
us we were talking about what would your
dream match be you could match up
against anybody ever in history and
you're like oh Trish Stratus and now
you're gonna have your dream come true
going up against Trish Stratus and
evolution how's it feel how do you
prepare I'm very excited to face Trisha
evolution this is a long time coming for
women to have our first ever all women's
pay-per-view and to be able to face such
an icon and hall-of-famer like Trish I'm
very excited it's gonna be a lot of fun
yeah and like I don't mean any
disrespect to the generations that have
come before you guys but your generation
of wrestlers right now you women are the
ones that are gonna be the icons in the
future there's gonna be a ton of you
there's like a handful of looming that
you can look at from the past and Trish
being maybe one of the top women in the
sport ever do you feel any nerves or
hesitation at all going up against her
I feel nerves and hesitation against
anyone that I go against especially
Trish you know she is you know
Trish Stratus and I'm very excited it's
it'll be a lot of fun I'm very very
interested to see how it'll go
mm-hmm Jeremy yeah because I saw Trish
at the women's Royal Rumble what she did
amazing and I was so upset that I wasn't
able to be in that match you know at the
time I was holding a title you know
can't problems yeah it's gonna be in the
world Rumble so to have this opportunity
to get in the ring especially because
every time I talked about it was like I
would love to get in the ring with Trish
or Lita you know someone from the era
that I watched anything to be able to
get the ring Oh Trish very excited how
does it happen is something that you
pushed for or talked about enough that
people were just listening I don't know
I found out on Twitter like everyone
else I got a tweet and I'm kind of
getting tagged all these tweets I was
like that can't be real like huzi
Photoshop and then WWE tweeted a and I
was like oh my gosh that's so crazy but
I was excited I had yeah my little elbow
freakout in my room it was great but now
this is gonna be a blockbuster event
evolution
he tells more about it what we can
expect the matchups are gonna be
phenomenal
obviously oh absolutely you know we have
women coming from then down forever yeah
I'm very excite you know we win it I
I'd imagine we have women from NXT yeah
you know women from the diva era yeah
Attitude Era our current roster I don't
know what the matches are you know we
don't know I found out on Twitter what
my club so I'm really excited to see
what the matchups will be and how it
will all pan out but I know it's gonna
be an amazing event and it's gonna be so
much action of these women and watching
this woman's evolution come together as
a whole and I'm very very intrigued to
see how it'll go but it's gonna be
awesome
are you prepared for how emotional a
night it's gonna be oh absolutely if it
never there was so much emotion in the
women's Royal Rumble match and I was
backstage on the women and they were all
just so emotional and excited and I feel
like evolution is gonna blow that out of
the water and it's it's gonna be we're
all gonna probably gonna need about a
week to recover from that emotion as a
fan growing up before he even got in is
there a match that you watch that just
like changed your life oh man changed my
life I don't know I mean I I was so
captivated by all the different styles
in WWE I don't know if I could actually
pinpoint a certain match that changed
forever but I I know that you know when
I was on table for three with Trish and
Lita we talked about how they may invent
it raw the first time women made about
it raw and how iconic that was and I
would say that definitely changed his
face for women in WWE as a whole yeah
can we talk a bit about your match with
rowdy Ronda Rousey at SummerSlam
I don't listen I don't want to bring up
a sore point but I did does it hurt
does it hurt and everything just looks
so powerful the moves are so fast that
my match was it was super intense yes it
was did it take a lot to recuperate from
yes I'm so recruiting I'm still
recovering from that and then I stuff I
know I also because you know when you
lose the title you have a rematch clause
these spoken any time and I just kind of
picked my right point you know when I'm
fully healed yes yeah I can't do it
right now yes I'm not really deal mom
I'm still sore come on
yeah so I gotta wait okay good good well
we'll wait for that one and while we
wait for that one
you know we've got braun strowman with
the Money in the Bank briefcase it's
cashed in it already as you talked to
you asking any advice about how to
properly handle the money in the bank
roll now let me ask you something mm-hmm
if a monster like braun strowman mm-hmm
came up to you yeah pretty sure he's not
asking for advice fair you can destroy
anything in his fat i don't think he's
gonna take advice from someone that's
five-foot right basically if someone
braun strowman's size comes out to me
it's just like the last time I took
advice from broad it was how to flip a
car so I don't think there's I don't
think I could actually teach him
anything you know because you know my my
cash in at money in the bank was very
strategic and I can't rely on my
strengths like he does I do rely on my
you know opportunities when they present
themselves you see you also got to be
cunning there's a mental game too I
don't underst
don't understand itself the guys are
like how much bran can learn from you
now we are here in Toronto there's a raw
show tonight it's very exciting I'm
excited for it when you're in this city
and you have any free time what is your
favorite thing to do do you like to get
out go to any place there's any
restaurants do anything in particular
I'd go to war ends oh yeah because we
have we have Tim Hortons growing up in
Ohio and I had one across the street for
me so it kind of brings you back to my
childhood whenever I see its importance
here that's kinda like what I do I would
go and get some Timbits yeah yeah I roll
up the rim cuz roll up the rim oh yeah I
remember those yeah I remember those
yeah I want to get I don't either
never I mean you you've won a title I've
literally won nothing no but the Tim
Hortons stuff I've never I've won titles
yeah hi
the roll of dough and I never never know
well I so thank you so much for sounds
amazing
thank you